hum
une bonne glace ça va faire du bien par
cette chaleur
ça fait mal à la tête je sais ça jette
un froid aujourd'hui je vous explique
tout ça l'histoire de ce dessert et
pourquoi la glace nous fait parfois mal
à la tête
[Musique]
vanille chocolat fraise citron nougat en
2020 les Français ont consommé
172000 tonnes de glace mais nous sommes
loin derrière nos voisins du nord
l'Estonie la Finlande la Lituanie la
Norvège ou la Belgique qui bonhomme
allant arrive dans le top 5 des plus
gros mangeurs de glace et notre goût
pour ce dessert ne date pas d'hier allez
retour à l'âge de glace n'exagérons rien
les tous premiers desserts glacés
remonteraient au moins à l'Antiquité
d'après la légende à la cour d'Alexandre
le Grand on se régalait de macédoine de
fruits mélangé à du miel et refroidit
avec de la neige à Rome l'emper Néron
lui se faisait livrer de la neige des
Alpes pour la mélanger à du vin et du
miel mais la véritable histoire de la
glace commence au 13ème siècle avec
Marco Polo il ramène en Italie la
technique mise au point par les Chinois
pour fabriquer des sorbets leurs secrets
refroidir artificiellement le récipient
contenant les ingrédients avec un
mélange de neige et de salpêtres trois
siècles plus tard un autre italien le
bien nommé Bernardo
guantalanti est le premier à intégrer du
lait dans la recette c'est ce qui va
donner naissance à la crème glacée avec
ce côté crémeux on aime encore
aujourd'hui et que les Français vont
découvrir grâce à Catherine de Médicis
qui glisse la recette dans son trousseau
lorsqu'elle traverse les Alpes pour
épouser Henri II en 1533 ce dessert
devient alors si populaire chez les
aristocrades Français qu'un grand nombre
d'entre eux se font construire à côté de
leur château des glaciaires des
réservoirs creusés dans le sol et
maçonnés conçue pour y conserver de la
glace toute l'année ce n'est pas fini
la crème glacée reste longtemps une
gourmandise réservée à l'élite elle se
popularise seulement à partir du 20e
siècle avec les progrès techniques
permettant de produire du froid plus
facilement et grâce à un petit coup de
pouce du hasard
durant l'hiver 1905 franquet-personne un
jeune Américain de 11 ans oublie son
verre de soda avec un agitateur devant
la porte de sa maison le lendemain après
une nuit très froide il découvre que sa
boisson a gelé le résultat
est délicieux il vient d'inventer le
bâtonnet glacé la suite dans la cuisine
glace glace à l'eau glace au lait glace
aux œufs crème glacée glace aux fruits
sorbet sorbet plat fruit il existe 8
grands types de glace reconnus
aujourd'hui par la profession et si les
parfums à la vanille ou à la fraise sont
les plus populaires ça n'empêche pas les
glaciers du monde entier de rivaliser
d'imagination pour mettre au point de
nouvelles saveurs parfois très
étonnantes glace
Omar au foie gras au piment à la pizza
une bonne glace au camembert ça vous dit
pourquoi pas mais écoute plutôt ça en
Angleterre un glacier a eu l'idée
lumineuse d'ajouter une protéine
extraite de Méduse dans de la crème
glacée résultat sa crème devient
luminescente quand on commence à la
lécher allez à un autre exemple à Dubaï
le scoopy Café propose une coupe Black
Diamond une glace à base de vanille de
Madagascar et de safran iranien
agrémenté de fines tranches de truffe
italienne et de paillettes d'or
comestibles 23 le tout servit dans une
coupelle Versace que l'on emporte après
dégustation le prix de cette petite
merveille plus de 700 euros 700 euros
ça fait mal au porte-monnaie non à la
tête ça c'est ce qui arrive quand on
avale sa glace trop vite c'est ce qu'on
appelle la céphalée de la crème glacée
je vous mets tout de suite au parfum
les scientifiques ne savent pas très
bien expliquer ce phénomène selon une
hypothèse quand on avale un gros morceau
de glace la température au fond de la
bouche baisse brutalement pour contact
du froid deux artères situées dans cette
région l'artère carotide et l'artère
cérébrale antérieure qui alimente le
cerveau se contracte avant de se dilater
la contraction des vaisseaux puis leur
dilatation au niveau du palais
engendrerait une douleur que l'on
assimile au mal de tête le nerf
trijumeau qui intervient notamment dans
la transmission des informations perçues
au niveau de la face serait impliqués
dans la transmission de ce message de
douleur il pourrait d'ailleurs s'agir de
ce que l'on appelle une douleur projetée
le problème se pose
au niveau du palais et c'est la tête le
front qui a mal on les boules pas de
panique ce mal de tête reste sans
gravité il ne dure pas plus de 20 à 30
secondes alors pour éviter le phénomène
il suffit tout simplement d'avaler de
petites bouchées de prendre le temps de
laisser fondre la glace sur la langue et
de faire des petites pauses entre deux
cuillères cela évite une baisse trop
brutale de la température au fond de la
gorge et maintenant un petit truc pour
réussir à confectionner de jolis couples
je sors le bac de glace du congélateur
et je le laisse environ une quinzaine de
minutes au réfrigérateur pour que la
température de la glace remonte un peu
idéalement à -9° j'utilise ensuite ce
que l'on appelle une cuillère
portionneuse à glace en inox comme
celle-ci et pourvu d'une partie mobile
qui permet de dégager la boule de glace
je commence par tremper la cuillère dans
de l'eau chaude pour la réchauffer puis
je l'essuie car l'eau chaude ferait
fondre la crème glacée à son contact
j'utilise ensuite ma cuillère pour
racler la surface de la crème glacée en
allant toujours vers l'avant jusqu'à
former une jolie boule et voilà pas mal
et vous comment aimez-vous la glace quel
parfum vous les préférez en coupe en
cornée en bâtonnets avec de la crème
chantilly et du chocolat fondu par
dessus n'hésitez pas à partager vos
goûts et vos toppings préférés en
commentaire avec à bientôt les
épicurieux et bonne dégustation leurs
secrets refroidir
artificiellement
dommage avec les progrès techniques
permettant de produire du froid plus
facilement
lorsqu'elle traverse les arbres
dommage on peut reprendre tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]